now, Belshazza was young,
egotistical,
filled with pride
and filled with his own self importance.
and Jesus was to say years later in Matthew 23
and whosoever shall exalt himself shall be abased.
if you try to tell how great you are and leave God out,
or if you act as though you can solve your own problems
and arrange your own life without the help of God,
God says, I'm going to bring you down.
and I would like to say
that to the leaders of our world,
you that are leaders of our world,
that do not give God the glory,
and do not put your trust totally in Him,
and think that you can solve the problems yourself,
you're going to come down according to the Scriptures,
and the Scriptures very clear about it.
whosoever shall exalt himself
shall be brought down, said Jesus.